on this tuesday night the damning
indictment of quebec's health care
system
a coroner's inquest concludes racism
contributed to joyce eshequan's death
her family's next steps the battle is
not over accusations of putting profits
over safety facebook's products harm
children stoke division and weaken our
democracy a whistleblower's blistering
testimony and the social giant's denials
rapid kova 19 tests coming to the
classroom this is an extra tool
to keep our children in the classroom
ontario's new strategy in some schools
and a flashback of the life that no
longer exists the unique fundraiser for
afghanistan's female journalists
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us a quebec coroner says she believes if
joyce eshequan had been a white woman
she would still be alive today while the
indigenous mother of seven lay dying in
a hospital she recorded health care
workers making racist remarks today the
coroner who presided over an inquiry
into eshequan's death explained why
systemic racism proved to be a fatal
factor mike armstrong has our top story
tonight and a warning the details are
disturbing
coroner gehen kimmel apologized and held
back tears talking about the toll her
investigation took on the family of joy
seshequan the death of the etiquette
woman a mother of seven she says didn't
have to happen so they say
coroner says eshequan's death was
directly related to her hospitalization
at the jolly at quebec hospital and
could have been avoided
by the time eshequan shot this
horrifying and now infamous video on
facebook live staff at the hospital had
already made a crucial mistake when she
was admitted a nurse identified eshequan
on her chart as a drug abuser in
withdrawal that wasn't the case eshequan
had gone to hospital with stomach pains
and would die two days later of a
build-up of fluid in her lungs
that would happen after staff insulted
her in the video laughing and telling
her she was better off dead and only
good for sex ponce vucker asked flat out
if eshequan would have been treated
differently and still be alive today if
she'd been white
should pass can we the coroner said
simply i think so yes
ashaquan's family says it will in the
coming days launch a civil lawsuit
against the hospital their lawyer says
it was the staff's prejudices that led
them to believe eshequan was a drug
abuser this information was entirely
erroneous and because of that label that
she was
given she was denied the health care
that was required by her condition
now the coroner is making a series of
recommendations in this case one of them
is that the province recognize systemic
racism
well that term is something the premier
pushes back on frasoligo admits there
was racism from the staff but insists
it's not bigger than that for me a
system
uh
it's all the system we have a lot of
work to do the tickimek chief says the
premier's resistance means more dialogue
is needed but for the family on this day
there is progress nothing
husband says part of their healing comes
through truth and more of that truth is
now
seeing daylight
mike armstrong global news montreal
ndp ethics critic charlie angus is
calling on justin trudeau to keep a
high-profile liberal out of cabinet less
than a week after prime minister trudeau
was spotted walking the beach into fino
bc on the first national day for truth
and reconciliation angus laid out his
recommendations for how trudeau should
move forward
in order to show that the government is
serious about a new direction
the prime minister needs to ensure that
carolyn bennett is no longer in the
cabinet
because it was under her watch that the
government spent millions in the
cover-up of the saint anne's legal
abuses
survivors from saint ann's residential
school in ontario are locked in a legal
fight with the federal government and
the catholic church over compensation
for the abuse they suffered
the ondario government is set to begin a
voluntary covenanting rapid testing
program in some schools it's an effort
to detect cases earlier and limit spread
796 schools in ontario have reported
cases of cova 19. that's about 16 of all
schools in the province in the past two
weeks there have been 1600 new
school-related infections more than 1400
were students right now six ontario
schools are closed due to covet 19. the
plan is to screen unvaccinated students
which for now is any child under 12.
ontario's top doctors initially resisted
the idea mike delay explains why they
changed course
one month into the school year ontario's
top doctor has seen enough starting next
week rapid testing will be rolled out to
select schools where the risk of
exposure to covet 19 is deemed high
if we're seeing a school that's in
trouble that's having consistent cases
that's at risk for closure this is an
extra tool
to keep our children in the classroom
the oddity is that it was only a few
weeks ago that dr kieran moore rejected
the idea of mass testing because of
false positives associated with the
rapid test besides testing 2 million
students a week was just too daunting
but while 81 percent of 12 to 17 year
olds in ontario have had one dose of the
vaccine and 73 percent are fully
vaccinated case rates among children
under 13 continued to grow
that's where a group of toronto area
parents stepped in and launched their
own testing program an idea that began
to snowball to other schools
they got their test kits through a
program called stay safe or at least
they did until the government recently
cut off supply stay safe was trying to
open access and the government seem to
be trying to close access and
you know i think they've really
responded to pressure i mean i think
they've seen that there's a huge demand
and desire for these tests among parents
across the province
it's a debate that's simmering across
the country in quebec rapid testing will
be widely available beginning next week
a step bc has avoided thus far although
it is expanding its mass mandate to
include all students kindergarten
through grade 12.
ontario's plan has been met with mixed
reaction because of its limitations
public health can target hot spots but
testing is entirely voluntary unless you
say we need a negative test for you to
come into school because we're in the
middle of an outbreak if most of the
parents decide not to test their kids
then there's very limited usefulness in
that test
ultimately there was too much public
demand for testing for ontario's top
doctors to ignore
and now they need to see results before
making any more tough decisions
microlight global news toronto
alberta is bringing back contact tracing
in schools do this we'll ramp up rapid
testing initiate contact notifications
and increase the public reporting that
families and many others rely on
covet cases are on the rise in alberta
among children between 5 and 11 years
old in regions where vaccination numbers
are low thanksgiving weekend will mark
the start of a two week long coven 19
circuit breaker in new brunswick the
restrictions go into effect at 6 pm
friday and apply only to hot spot areas
people in the affected zones will be
limited to their household bubbles and
non-essential travel into those areas
will be prohibited schools and
businesses will remain open new
brunswick's active case load is higher
than at any other point in the pandemic
there are more blistering accusations
against facebook a whistleblower who
worked as a data scientist claims a
social media giant is driven by money
and suffers from moral bankruptcy
speaking at a senate subcommittee
francis hogan accused the trillion
dollar company of using misinformation
to incite hate and as jennifer johnson
reports she puts the blame squarely on
its founder mark zuckerberg
i'm here today because i believe
facebook's products harm children stoke
division
and weaken our democracy time and again
francis haugen the facebook product
manager and data analyst turned
whistleblower spoke firmly before u.s
lawmakers making the case that facebook
continues to mislead the public about
its own damning research and is overdue
for regulation one faced with conflicts
of interest between its own profits and
the common good public safety that
facebook consistently chose to
prioritize its profits last month haugen
filed anonymous complaints with federal
authorities claiming the social media
giant allows misinformation because
divisive news feeds receive more user
attention which allows facebook to
charge advertisers more the dangers of
engagement based ranking are that
facebook knows
that content that elicits an extreme
reaction from you is more likely to get
a click a comment or re-share she also
slammed instagram which facebook owns
saying the company ignores its own
evidence showing instagram makes eating
disorders and thoughts of suicide worse
for young girls facebook knows that
they are leading young users to anorexia
content lawmakers have heard enough mark
zuckerberg ought to be looking at
himself in the mirror
today
and yet rather than taking
responsibility
and showing leadership
mr zuckerberg is going sailing i've been
arguing for some time that it is time
for congress to act haugen left facebook
with tens of thousands of internal
research documents she secretly copied
while working in the company's civic
integrity unit facebook which has 2.8
billion users worldwide denies the
allegations since 2016 we've spent 13
billion dollars on safety and security
we have 40 000 people working on safety
and security but facebook says it is
open to more oversight the white house
says self-regulation by social media
platforms isn't working and it's past
time for congress to crack down
jennifer johnson global news washington
conservative mps met in ottawa today for
the first time since their election
defeat the party saw 119 members of
parliament elected in last month's
election slightly less than it did in
2019 aaron o'toole is facing criticism
as leader and as michael couture reports
some members of caucus are concerned he
shifted the tories too close to the
center
thank you
newly elected mps and returning members
of the conservative caucus walked the
gauntlet of reporters with one question
on everyone's mind would you still
support mr o'toole
absolutely
but not everyone was offering a
full-throated endorsement
i support aaron o'toole's vision for
canada that was ontario mp michael
barrett during the campaign moderating
some of those virtual town halls and
this
is now it'll be incumbent on him to to
demonstrate that the lessons that
the lessons that caucus expresses today
that they're learned before we move
forward alberta mp shannon stubbs came
to the meeting demanding answers
why we lost capable competent
conservatives in urban areas and i do
want to hear
a clear roadmap on how we are going to
win those areas based on conservative
values because conservatives should
campaign as conservatives the tories
voted for the reform act meaning the
caucus has the power to remove o'toole
but for now he seems unfazed by the
uncertainty
this is not about
a sort of damocles hanging over my head
we're united as a team this is about
having a fair and transparent process
that a team must have when it respects
one another for electing a chair for
making determinations about membership
in the caucus and about leadership
o'toole might not feel threatened but
this conservative strategist believes
the leader needs to be careful welcome
to the conservative party it's like
being the turkey at the thanksgiving
dinner somebody's always nibbling at you
and cutting a bit off of you and looking
for the stuffing because it's so tasty
o'toole has committed to a full review
of what went wrong during the election
and that will be led by former edmonton
mp james [ __ ] in the meantime the
conservative leader is keen to get back
to work as the leader of the opposition
and prove to his caucus he deserves to
keep his job
robin mike like a tour in ottawa thanks
mike
france has released a damning report
looking at sexual abuse in the catholic
church an independent commission
estimates that 330 000 french children
were victimized by priests and church
officials over the past 70 years it is
estimated that 80 percent of the victims
were boys the commission worked for two
and a half years listening to victims
and witnesses as well as going through
church court and police archives the
head of the victims group is calling on
the church for compensation the pope
says he wants to see the church of
france embark on a path of redemption in
the wake of the investigation
a new round of pipeline politics coming
up what ottawa just did to keep the
controversial line five running
let this be a crude history lesson for
michigan's governor the canadian
government is invoking a treaty that
dates back to the late 70s to prevent
the shutdown of the enbridge line 5.
that pipeline carries oil from western
canada through the great lakes states to
southwestern ontario as eric sorensen
reports the border battle is not only
pitting canada against the u.s but
economists against environmentalists
the oil refined in sarnia's chemical
valley keeps traffic moving and
buildings heated in much of ontario and
quebec so the enbridge pipeline through
michigan is a crucial lifeline to the
canadian economy but michigan's governor
has gone to court to bring an end to
line five we bear all of the risk for a
foreign company
to just move their move their product
through and and it's ridiculous we gotta
shut it down the governor points to a
separate enbridge pipeline that leaked
and badly contaminated a michigan river
ten years ago though line five's legacy
is long and relatively clean
construction of the 90 million dollar
inter-provincial pipeline from edmonton
alberta to superior wisconsin the first
phase of the pipeline to the u.s was
built 70 years ago then in the early 50s
line five was constructed through
michigan to sarnia ontario between
michigan's upper and lower peninsulas
more than six kilometers of that
pipeline crosses the mackinaw straits
it's this sensitive area that most
worries michigan's governor the light
oil and natural gas liquids delivered by
our line five pipeline enbridge says
there's never been a leak here and
proposes to build a tunnel into the
riverbed and bury the pipeline to
protect it from rupturing but michigan
wants to shut off the oil so canada has
invoked a 1977 nation donation treaty
which ottawa says prevents michigan from
interfering with in any way the
transmission of hydrocarbon in transit
it shows how high the stakes are what if
this was shut down in the next two or
three months this would truly be uh
you know chaos dealing with people's
lives in their homes the us has certain
obligations to its uh treaty partner the
canadians it's awkward for president
biden who visited michigan today he
doesn't want to offend canada or
democratic progressives like governor
whitmer but ottawa is forcing
washington's hand by invoking the treaty
canada will ask the federal government
of the united states to
take control of the issue and preempt
michigan the treaty between prime
minister pierre trudeau and president
jimmy carter came during the energy
crisis of the 1970s the americans wanted
less dependence on middle east oil and
trudeau's approval for alaskan gas
through this country 44 years later it
is canada that has turned to the treaty
to ensure its energy can keep flowing
erik sorensen global news toronto
still ahead how the pandemic is raising
the bar for mental health benefits
over the course of the pandemic many
canadians have been struggling with
their mental well-being new polling from
ipsos shows 28 of canadians admit their
mental health has deteriorated as a
result there is more demand for
counseling and support but azan gaviola
reports benefits for workers are often
limited
i was doubting myself a lot didn't feel
like i could meet challenges head-on the
way that i usually could amber smith hit
an emotional wall in february she says
it was taking a toll on her work and her
personal relationships so she tried
something she's never done before she
started seeing a psychologist it's been
you know tough to feel isolated and like
you don't have access to your
friends and family in the way that you
would it was really hard to just feel
like yourself millennials and gen z are
most likely to admit it's a struggle
when you ask them to self-report their
level of mental health they are more
likely to report it as poor or bad
compared to their older counterparts
there's been a huge spike in virtual
therapy sessions at the ontario shores
center for mental health mirroring a
trend seen right across the country we
used to do about
400 virtual care visits a month
pre-pandemic
and
we are now doing anywhere between
4 000 and 6 000 virtual care visits
a month given how competitive the labor
market has become employers who want to
keep and attract the best workers need
to consider offering mental health
benefits if they don't already and
increasing caps the majority of the
plans still provide a fairly modest
amount maybe 500 a year in support for
that type of coverage and so um you know
depending on your personal needs it may
not be enough i also value an employer
though who creates an environment like a
workplace of well-being where i know i
can come to work and i can find support
on those days when i don't feel myself
the pandemic has raised the bar for
mental health support in the workplace
ann gaviola global news toronto
up next more than a thousand words the
exhibit and support of women who can no
longer practice their craft
get this a russian actor and director
are on a mission to shoot the first
feature film in orbit the soyuz
spacecraft has now docked at the
international space station the
three-person crew will spend about two
weeks filming segments for the challenge
and by the way nasa is working with
hollywood actor tom cruise to shoot a
film in space later this year
stunning photographs of life in
afghanistan are being sold in support of
the country's female journalists the
images were taken over two decades by
photojournalists many of whom are no
longer allowed to work under taliban
rule as our europe bureau chief crystal
gomezing reports the pictures of the
past are being used to create hope for
the future
photos of a life that no longer exists
these images commissioned over the years
by the associated press are poignant
reminders in sharp focus of what's been
lost almost a very precious thing to
hold on to sort of
you know in a way archive a world that
seemed to be disappearing really fast
since the taliban seized control of
afghanistan in august women are
noticeably absent from the streets of
kabul and the majority of girls are no
longer going to school
the network of women in media india
launched a photo fundraiser
in support of women no longer able to
practice their craft farida nixon
co-founded an independent news network
but with the taliban's resurgence she
made the gut-wrenching decision to leave
her husband and son and flee the country
with her daughter she's now in canada i
am here and i am happy that at least i
have my pen and not at least i have my
voice
and will continue this advocacy
advocating for press freedom and for
women to be allowed to participate fully
in society the photography fundraiser
has so far collected more than 70
thousand dollars u.s to support women
isolated in their homes unable to earn a
living the main effort between behind
this fundraiser is
you know somewhere addressing the sense
and we've heard it through several women
journalists who've said the world has
abandoned us
the fundraiser offers canadians and
others around the world another
opportunity to help improve the lives of
afghans
crystal gomencing global news
london
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm robin gill tonight we
leave you with a dynamic duo proving
they'll go the distance to spread joy
[Music]
bach and bungara together at last gertie
punder dances in yukon while ireland's
patrick dexter plays cello more than 6
000 kilometers away what a great
collaboration thank you for watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]